Hello and welcome,
everyone. This is the third applied
active inference symposium enacting
ecosystems of shared intelligence. It is
August 22, 2023. We have a
lot of really awesome presentations and
sessions coming up in the first interval
and in the second interval. So let's
just get right into it with our first
talk. This will be by Andre Bastos. So,
Andre, thank you for joining and looking
forward to your talk. Thank you very
well, Daniel. And thank you for the
other organizers of the Active Inference
Conference and Symposium here. I'm glad
to be talking to you guys today about my
work. The title of the presentation is
multilaminar Multi Area Recordings and
the Non Human primate that's these guys
right here, macaque monkeys, suggest
that predictive coding is implemented
via predictive routing. And so what do
we mean by these things? Well, just as a
point of introduction, I'd like to start
by just saying that I
started out working with Karl Friston in
about 2010, and we were really
interested in trying to map the
neurobiology of the predictive coding
circuits that have been theorized and
hypothesized onto cortical laminar
architecture, which you can see here.
And in that work with him, we proposed
that different layers and different
oscillations were involved in either
capturing and calculating prediction
error or predictions. And so what
we do in my lab and I recently started
as an assistant professor in the
Department of Psychology at Vanderbilt.
And so what we do is we train rhesus
macaque monkeys on tasks which are more
or less predictable and that have
different sensory elements that are more
or less predictable, and we'll get into
what that looks like. And then we use
multilaminar probes, so high density
probes with dozens or hundreds of
contacts that can record across
different layers. And so this is a
beautiful drawing here of what the
layers look like of Cortex by Santiago
Ramoni Cajal over 100 years ago. And you
can see this really beautiful layered
architecture. Layer 1234 is this dense
one. In the middle five, you get these
large pyramidal neurons, and then six on
the bottom. And so we're interested in
my lab primarily at two levels of
explanation. The first is, what do these
neurons spike to? What makes them fire
action potentials and excites them? And
do they get more or less excitable
depending on how predictable stimuli
are? And second, how do they oscillate?
In which frequency bands does rhythmic
activity tend to cause them to fire more
or less action potentials? And so we
record across layers in one area over
here, but we might put in our electrodes
in several other areas so that we can
also capture aspects of cortical
communication. And these oscillations in
this communication, we think, is really
intimately linked to the interaction
between inhibitory cells, these cells in
red here, and excitatory neurons, these
cells in black that I've drawn. Okay,
so without further ado, let's just dive
right into it here. So here's the
outline of my talk in part one we're
going to be talking about first an
overview of what do we actually mean by
this predictive coding model and how do
we think it may be mapped onto cortex
and paying special attention to the
neurophysiology. So here's the bird's
eye overview of predictive coding at the
level that maybe a neurobiologist or a
cognitive scientist or a cognitive
neuroscientist might need to know about
in order to be able to apply it to
their own work. And so, here's what
I mean by predictive coding, that
there's a hypothesized circuit that is
especially rich in higher order areas.
So here's like the front of the brain,
which learns about these statistical
regularities of the world and creates
predictions about what is going to be
seen and felt and touched and so on in
the next moment in time and in this
moment in time, and sends those
predictions to earlier parts of the
brain. So, to lower order cortex receive
these predictions and sensory inputs,
the inputs coming from the eyes and ears
and all of our sensorium is then
compared to this top down prediction.
And if there's a mismatch, that's a
prediction error and the prediction
error is sped forward. It's a mismatch
response and it can be used to drive
models, drive these internal
representations in order to be better
over time and to make better
predictions. And in particular,
these prediction errors are hypothesized
to be housed in superficial layers of
cortex. And so that's a hypothesis that
we've been able to test now with these
laminar electrodes. So let's see how our
experimental design worked in order for
us to be able to look at the difference
between predictable and unpredictable
sensory stimuli. So we train monkeys on
what's called a delayed match to sample
task. It's a classic task of working
memory, where monkeys are trained to
fixate on the center of the screen.
Then there's a visual stimulus, in this
case a car stimulus that's shown.
There's a brief delay in which that
stimulus has to be held in working
memory. Then the animal is tested on
which of the three items was in working
memory. The animal makes a correct
response when they saka, in this case to
the upper left, to indicate that the car
stimulus was last shown. So we then
manipulated the predictability of this
information that was to enter working
memory in the following way. For 50
trials in a row, we would either keep
the sample stimulus constant,
so car, car, and that's being depicted
by the a here, or in another context,
there would be an unpredictable sampling
regime where either the car orange or
green could be sampled at any moment in
time. So the animals went back and forth
in being in a predictable context or an
unpredictable context. And then we asked
the question, what does brain activity
look like when the exact same stimulus
is processed in a predictable regime
versus an unpredictable regime. And in
order to do this work, we implanted
these monkeys with multilaminar probes.
So these are probes, again with these at
that time that I did this work, about a
dozen or so or maybe up to 32 contacts.
Nowadays we can go into the several
hundreds of contacts along a single
probe. We can use MRI guidance in order
to position those probes perpendicular
to cortex such that they'll span each of
the six cortical layers, layer one
through six. Here you can see the white
matter here below. And then we sampled
from different parts of both the visual
cortex because, remember, those are the
areas that might issue prediction errors
in the case of an unpredictable sample
as well as higher order cortex which has
been hypothesized to create these
internal models that then issue
predictions. So here's what we found.
We first just analyzed the multiunit
activity which is a measure of the spike
rate. So how many action potentials per
unit of time are these neurons firing?
And what's being shown here is the
multiunit activity as a difference
between when that sample was
unpredictable minus predictable. So
positive activity means more activity
during an unpredictable sample I-E-A
violation of a prediction or a putative
prediction error signal. And all
throughout the brain from V four, the
sensory area all the way to these higher
order frontal parietal regions we saw,
without any exception that neurons were
much more excitable when they were
processing an unpredictable stimulus
compared to predictable stimulus. And
also, not surprisingly, this started
already at the feed forward sweep of
activity such that these red bars here
indicate the start of significance. So
sure enough, area V four was the first
to show significance. So more spiking to
the unpredictable, over predictable.
And this activity fed forward up the
cortical hierarchy. Next, we looked
not only at the firing rate of these
neurons but also the local field
potential which is informative about the
local oscillatory activity that's
present. So you can think of these
oscillations as massive waves of
activity that are synchronous across a
large population of neurons but of
course, are produced through the
interplay between these recurrent
inhibitory bouts of activity. And so,
here's what we found. We performed this
power spectral analysis again comparing
power in the unpredictable case versus
power in the predictable case. And we
did a percent change metric. Very simple
percent change metric. So again, what's
shown here on the Y axis is in positive,
more power to unpredictable samples and
in the negative values, more power to
the predictable samples. Now, what we
saw in the gamma range so that's
everywhere above about 30 or 40 Hz again
in all areas very strongly mirrored what
we saw in the spiking activity. Namely,
that there was more of this high
frequency and also the classic low range
frequency in the gamma range. So in both
the low gamma and high gamma ranges an
enhancement of power during the
unpredictable cues. That was also the
case in the theta band. And this makes
somewhat sense from the point of view of
neurophysiology that this theta
frequency and this gamma frequency,
they very often track one another and do
similar things in cortex. Why exactly
that is the case? We actually don't know
what the reason for that is, but that's
an observation that we've seen in many
other tasks. But what we saw in between
the theta and the gamma bands was this
other band at between ten to about 20 or
slightly higher in frequency, this
classic alpha beta band. And this alpha
beta band, this alpha beta band
acted in the exact opposite way.
Namely, there was more power to
predictable samples than to
unpredictable samples. With one
exception. Area seven A was an
exception. It did have that canonical
pattern in the alpha band, but in the
low beta band, it was actually similar
to gamma. And we think that this might
be a working memory update mechanism.
But for now, we are really stressing and
emphasizing the fact that across all of
these areas, you had this beta signal
that was stronger to the predictable
case, to the predictable sample. Okay,
so next we had these laminar electrodes.
So let's look at the difference between
what these neurons are doing when you
record from the so called superficial
layers of cortex versus the so called
deep layers of cortex. So the
superficial layers are layers two,
three. The deep layers are these layers
five and six. These superficial layers,
they are the layers that feed forward.
So remember from that introductory slide
that these are the layers that were
hypothesized based on predictive coding
theory to house the prediction error
neurons, because according to theory,
those prediction error signals are sent
in the feed forward direction. So we
then tested that in a second way, which
was to test whether or not those
enhanced signals during unpredictable
samples are more present in layer two,
three. And that's exactly what we found
in V four. So when we again take this
spiking signal and subtract
unpredictable, minus predictable
spiking, we see that the signal is more
enhanced in superficial layers of D
four. There was a trend towards that in
PFC as well, but in D four, it was a
significant observation. And
furthermore, when we now look at the LFP
gamma power, this power in the 40 to 90
Hz band, again, we do the power change.
So these positive signals mean there's
an enhancement of gamma power to the
unpredictable signal. And again, now in
both V four and PFC, it's the
superficial layers that are having more
of this unpredictable signal again,
and that's consistent with the theorized
type of circuitry for these canonical
circuits. Next, we were
interested in whether or not these power
changes were blankets across the board
that just overall increase mu activity
and GAM activity independent of the
exact sample that was being shown or
whether these signals were actually
specific to the actual item that was
being predicted. Because remember, in
our task design, animals were for a
large portion of time predicting that
there should be a car stimulus or
predicting an orange or predicting the
green stimulus. So in that particular
task requirement, it wouldn't make sense
if task representations for all three
stimuli all went up to an unpredictable
stimuli that would be more consistent
with just an overall arousal signal.
But what we were next interested in is
whether or not neurons that actually
were selective for the car, if it was
those neurons in particular that had the
unpredictable signals. And what we found
is that that was indeed the case. So we
performed the same analysis as before,
LFP gamma power difference for
unpredictable, minus, predictable, but
now as a function of whether or not
those neurons preferred the stimulus
that was being predicted. And what we
found is that the preference actually
modulated this gamma band activity very
strongly. And so this unpredictable
signal change was more specific to
neurons that actually preferred that
predicted stimulus, indicating that this
prediction was not acting as a blanket
similar to an arousal mechanism, but was
actually reaching down at the level of
the representations that were specific
to the thing that needed to be
predicted. And that was even more the
case in the beta frequency range
actually, where the neurons that didn't
encode the predicted stimulus, they
couldn't care less whether or not that
stimulus was predictable.
It was really only neurons that carried
information about the stimulus that was
being predicted. Those were the neurons
that were not enhancing
but diminishing their beta during an
unpredictable signal or said another
way, enhancing their beta to a predicted
signal change. So here's what we think
is going on. We call this
neurophysiological implementation that
we found of predictive coding. We call
it predictive routing to make a semantic
point, but also a slightly more
neurophysiological and computational
argument that we don't actually find
strong evidence for this mismatch and
prediction signal at the level of
neurons, but instead we think that this
prediction circuit exists but
uses these oscillations in order to
implement what is predicted. So here's
how we think this works. So when a
prediction matches a stimulus, as is
being shown here, when you're predicting
A and you get a stimulus A, then the A
column. In other words, it doesn't have
to be a column, but the area of the
brain or the neurons that encode A are
going to become prepared to receive the
stimulus A by enhancing the power of
this alpha beta signal. So this top down
beta from higher order areas we think
prepares a cortical circuit to receive a
predicted stimulus and it prepares that
stimulus by enhancing that's. This up
arrow here, the alpha beta, especially
in the deep layers, which can inhibit
both the gamma and the spiking signal in
the superficial layers as a result.
So this top down signal inhibits the
superficial layers and as a result,
there is decreased gamma and spiking and
decreased feed forward output in the
case of a predictable stimulus. The case
of an unpredictable stimulus, well,
stimulus A, just like before, is still
going to be coming in. But because it's
not predictable, that column, that set
of neurons that normally represents A,
was not previously prepared by an alpha
beta signal. And so the alpha beta
signal is relatively low in an
unpredictable context, releasing the
inhibition that the deep layers exert on
superficial layers and as a result,
causing more gamma, more spiking and
more feed forward output. In other
words, what we are hypothesizing here is
that predictive coding and this error
computation comes about as a failure in
predictive inhibition. And as a result
of the lack of these mechanisms being in
place during an unpredictable stimulus,
there is an enhanced gamma output. And
that's what we call a prediction error,
or that's what we interpret as a
prediction error. So here's the
predictive routing model one more time
in a predictable stimulus, top down
inputs prepare the column to receive a
stimulus. That preparation leads to
inhibition, less feed forward output.
In an unpredictable case, those
mechanisms aren't in place, as a result,
more feed forward gamma output. So
that's part one. That's our cortical
neurophysiological hypothesis then,
that we call predictive routing of how
we believe predictive coding is
implemented in the brain. And next I
want to turn to a little bit more about
how these rhythms are actually produced
in the brain, because one of the things
that we noticed from just placing our
laminar electrodes into cortex is that
independent of where we put our probe.
So here's an example of prefrontal
cortex activity. We would see these high
frequency gamma waves and superficial
layers and slower frequency alpha beta
waves in these deep layers. And you
can do this analysis very easily and
quickly to reveal this, what we call
spectrolaminer pattern. And what this
is, is simply dividing each contact on
the probe, dividing the power that you
observe at that contact by the maximum,
by the contact with the maximum power
along the probe. And what this does is
it normalizes power such that a value of
one is the layer that had the most power
at that particular frequency band. And
so, if you look here on the x axis,
this is frequency. So these red colors
are tracking which particular layer has
more power at that frequency. So you see
more of this low and high gamma power in
the superficial layers. So that's above
zero on the y axis and more of this
alpha beta activity in the deeper layers
of the cortex. And so in
a large scale survey of
cortex, together with Bob DeSimone's
Lab and Diego. And so I did this
partially while I was at MIT, when I was
a postdoc with Earl Miller. And I
continued this. Now at Vanderbilt. So
this was a really cross institutional
study and involved multiple labs.
And the reason that that was important
is that most labs specialize in being a
prefrontal cortex lab, or a V four lab,
or an lip lab, et cetera. And relatively
few investigators had actually done the
necessary work to be able to record with
these laminar probes in multiple areas
simultaneously. And so, therefore, by
coordinating and pooling data from
multiple experiments, we were able to
record from a total of 14 areas in this
study that we have now in review.
And what we found was that independent
of the area, we found a spectral laminar
pattern that was highly conserved
across areas. And so here it is from
zero to 150 Hz for area V four in the
sensory cortex, seven A in parietal
cortex, prefrontal cortex in the front
of the brain. Everywhere we looked, we
found that there was this enhanced gamma
power in these red lines here in
superficial layers, and enhanced alpha
beta power in the deeper layers.
And what we then turn to next is,
first of all, well, let's really confirm
at a histological anatomical level that
it's really these layers. Is it layer
one, is it layer two, is it four that
expresses gamma? And the same question
for beta. Let's really confirm that that
is in fact the case, because it seemed
like a very prominent hypothesis and a
very prominent observation. We wanted to
really confirm it. So that's the first
part of this, part two. And then we're
going to get into which specific
mechanisms might generate these
oscillations and how does that inform
computational modeling? And so then this
was work done in my lab at Vanderbilt,
led by a very talented undergraduate
student, actually, Max Lichtenfeld. And
so we performed these histological
reconstructions. Here's the probe, an
example probe where we performed these
tiny electrolytic lesions in particular
areas while we were recording here's the
overlay of the laminar boundaries. So in
red here, this is layer four. And then,
of course, we had the electrophysiology
so we could look at the gamma power,
gamma relative power, the beta relative
power, and the point at which they cross
over, actually, we determined was
pretty consistent in layer four. And of
course, then we also mapped on the other
features of these things to the layers.
And so here's what we found is that the
crossover, the point at which the gamma
profile in red and the beta profile in
blue, the point at which they cross
over, at which their powers are equal,
that tended to land in layer four. The
peak gamma power tended to land in layer
two or three, and the peak beta power
tended to land in layer five or six.
And so we mapped these distances between
these different electrophysiological
signatures or distinct
profiles to the different layers. And we
did this for several different probes
and for several different animals until
we were able to get a very nice
distribution here, which confirmed that
indeed, the gamma beta crossover is
consistent with being at laminar
position zero. We called the middle of
layer four, whereas this gamma is at the
boundary between layer two, three and
beta at the boundary between layer five
and six. And so here is our current toy
model of what we think is going on. So
we think that there's different
inhibitory neurons that are interacting
with their excitatory cell partners to
generate fast frequency gamma activity
in the superficial layers and in turn
that there is another type of
interneuron that is generating with
slower time constants this alpha beta
rhythmic activity. So in order
to examine this, we again turn to
anatomy, we again turn to this question,
well then, which exact inhibitory
neurons are most prominent therefore in
the layers that express these different
frequencies? And in order to perform
this work, what we did is we quantified
the laminar expression of three distinct
interneuron subtypes that are known to
account for over 90% of the inhibitory
interneurons in the primate brain. And
those inhibitory neuron subtypes are
parvalbumin positive calretin,
calbindin positive. And importantly,
previous computational modeling work had
really singled out the parvalbumin cell
class as the critical class for
generating these gamma oscillations
because of their fast time constants and
strong synapses onto the cell bodies of
excitatory neurons. And so again we
perform this painstaking histological
analysis where you perform different
stains, mounting cover, slipping
microscopy, semiautomated thresholding
and cell counting in order to be able to
then really have a quantitative view on
which layers have which cell types that
are most associated with these
frequencies. And so here's what this
data then looks like. We have the gamma
and alpha beta electrophysiology here,
and then at the same time we have the
presence of different neuron types with
the three inhibitory cell classes here.
And then we can perform an analysis to
determine which of these cell classes is
most strongly associated with the gamma.
And here's what we found that in both
the low gamma and the high gamma across
over 14 regions, what we found quite
significantly was that it was really the
parvalbumin cell counts shown here
as a function of laminar depth that were
giving us the best explanation for the
laminar profile of the gamma rhythmic
activity. Both when you take a very wide
band as well as when you perform a low
versus high gamma split, it comes out in
both ways. So how can this inform
computational models of oscillations?
Well, here's what we think is going on
then. We collaborated with several
people here on this work, including
Sanchez Toto et al and
computational modelers in Spain. And
what we did was we performed an analysis
where we took different
interneurons with different types of
connectivity. So these PV, these
parvalbumin interneurons were modeled as
having strong inhibitory connections to
the pyramidal cell class and strong self
inhibition, which has been important for
gamma oscillations previously. And when
you hook them up in these particular
ways, sure enough, and you measure the
spectral output of these neurons, these
p two neurons, superficial parameter
neurons, sure enough, they express
gamma. And when you put in different
types of interneurons with slower time
constants and different types of
connections to these deep layer neurons,
sure enough, they come out with more
alpha beta oscillations. So indeed,
this anatomical work could produce even
more in the future, even more
accurate models of how these
interneurons work together and with
parameter cells across different layers
in order to express these oscillations.
So this is really a work in progress and
one of the first steps towards this and
our ultimate aim is to really pull
together this rich anatomical and
neurophysiological data together with
computational models to be able to
approximate the laminar structure of
cortex to a better and better degree.
This next part here, I'll talk a little
bit about a causal test now of the
predictive routing model with propofol
anesthesia. So this will be the last
part of the talk here. And so we
were interested in anesthesia. I got
interested in anesthesia actually
through my work and contact with Jake
Donahue over here, who is a very
talented MD PhD student at MIT
at the time and was
being co mentored by Emory Brown and
Earl Miller, who was also my mentor.
And so we became interested in this
topic for the following reason. Well,
first of all, as surprising as this may
seem, if you go into a surgical clinic
and you're administered an anesthetic
such as propofol, well, it turns out
that the anesthesiologist may not know
exactly the cortical mechanisms and the
systems level mechanisms for how that
anesthetic is actually working in the
brain. And it's actually to this day
remains more often than
not the case that there's actually no
intraoperative monitoring of brain
state. It's far and few between the
anesthesiologists that are actually
doing that. And so Emory Brown, who's an
anesthesiologist himself, is really
pushing for more and more adoption
of simple tools like EEG and spectral
estimation methods by the clinic.
And so our work was clinically
motivated, but it was also motivated by
the ability to test this predictive
routing model when activity,
especially in prefrontal cortex areas,
is relatively silenced. And so in these
experiments, we administered propofol to
again these rhesus macaques and we
recorded brain activity there's, these
local field potentials and spiking
activity in the awake state as well as
in the unconscious state. And what we
first noticed is that in the unconscious
state, there were these slow rhythmic
bouts of activity at about 1 cycle per
second, or slightly little faster, a
little slower than that. Those are the
slow frequencies. And these slow
frequencies organize these massive bouts
of spiking, which could sometimes be
very synchronous across cortex,
but that there were long periods of
silence in between these bouts of
spiking in the unconscious state. And so
propofol anesthesia, we found is
accompanied by, again, these strong
increases in slow frequency activity,
which create alternating on and off
periods for spiking. There's reduced
spiking activity throughout the network,
but the strongest reductions are in
prefrontal cortex. And sensory areas
are relatively spared. So they're still
quite reduced in their excitability in
the unconscious state, but prefrontal
cortex is more inhibited. There is also,
we found reductions in cross area
synchrony and very pronounced reductions
in the alpha beta band. And so as a
result, we thought we could actually use
this model, this propofol anesthetic
model, in order to test certain aspects
of predictive routing. Because what's
going on here? We have lower order
cortex that's hypothesized to feed
forward prediction errors to higher
order cortex. And in turn,
these higher order areas might feed back
their predictions. But as a result of
propofol, these higher order areas are
profoundly impaired and very reduced
in their spiking activity. And the alpha
beta rhythm is also the synchrony
between areas is highly reduced. So
what's going to happen in this case?
Well, if you think from the point of
view of simply everything is going down,
then sensory areas in a response to an
unpredictable stimulus should also just
go down. But if you think from a
predictive coding or a predictive
routing point of view, the function of
these higher order areas is to create
feedback predictions that inhibit
activity. So in the absence of those
feedback inhibitory activities, you
might actually hypothesize that there
would be an enhancement of the feed
forward response when that feed forward
response is characterized by an
unpredictable stimulus or prediction
error. And so we sought to test this out
using the simple sensory prediction
paradigm where we have a tone stimuli.
These tone stimuli could either be
repeated or occasionally there could be
an oddball stimulus.
And what we would expect is that there
would be enhanced feedback predictions
when stimuli were repeatable and
predicted, and that the occasion of an
oddball would signal an enhanced gamma
feed forward signal. So we performed
the auditory stimulation task, both in
the awake state as well as after there
was an administration of propofol
leading to loss of consciousness. And
here's what we found in the local state,
just as we found in the visual cortex
for an unpredictable visual stimulus,
as in the visual cortex, so in the
sensory cortex, my PhD student Sophie
Shang, who performed this analysis,
found an enhanced gamma. So right at the
time of the local oddball. So we have
time here on the x axis frequency on the
y axis, and spectrogram hot colors
mean more activity to an unpredictable
stimulus. So there was an enhanced gamma
response to this unpredictable stimulus,
decreased alpha beta to the
unpredictable stimulus. Or set another
way, when the stimulus was predicted,
there was more alpha beta. And here's
what happened in the anesthetized state
when we performed this exact same
contrast, we lost the. Predictable alpha
beta signal and instead everything was
enhanced. So there was a decrease in
frequency towards the low gamma
range. So the cortex just essentially
went into a constant ringing in the
gamma frequency range, which to our
surprise was much stronger in power
compared to the gamma that we saw being
enhanced during an unpredictable
stimulus in the awake state. And the way
we interpret this is that in the absence
of this inhibitory predictive alpha beta
signal, this gamma signal becomes
uncontrolled and enhances itself in
the local anesthetized state. Here in
area TPT is a sensory area, should have
mentioned that. So now to conclude,
we propose predictive routing. So
predictive routing is a
neurophysiologically inspired
implementation of predictive coding,
which stresses the importance of these
alpha beta signals for implementing
predictions and inhibiting sensory areas
and areas of the brain that are
experiencing a predictable stimulus. In
the absence of that, you get an enhanced
feed forward gamma output. And this
distinction between gamma and beta
across layers we found was ubiquitous
across cortex, really suggesting that
something like this may in fact be truly
a canonical circuit motif that's
repeated across the brain.
And these alphabetarhmic predictive
preparation or inhibition we found, we
observed was lost in the unconscious
state, with unconsciousness being
mediated by propofol. By the way, it's
one of the most often used anesthetics,
and that as a result of this loss of
predictive alpha beta, there was an
enhanced gamma modulation to these
unpredictable inputs. In other words,
the sensory cortex was in a disinhibited
state. And so with that, I'd like to
thank my many collaborators and the
Bostos lab at Vanderbilt, as well as
collaborators on the anatomy and
collaborators at MIT, as well as my
financial support. And lastly, we just
started the lab about two years ago,
we're still in recruiting stage, so you
guys can check out my website, my ex
Twitter feed, and email me if interested
in contributing to this line of
research. And so with that, I'll turn it
over in case there are any questions.
Thank you for your attention.
Awesome. Thank you andre, I'll just ask
one quick question from the chat, dave
Douglas asks, does propofol
change the activity of neuronal
microtubules in any interesting way?
Thanks Andre. I'll just ask one question
from the chat Dave Douglas asks, does
propofol change the activity of neuronal
microtubes in any interesting way?
I haven't looked into the microtube
kind of hypothesis, that's one of the
hypotheses advocated for many years
by people like Stuart Hammerhoff, and
there has been some recent work done by
George Masure, I believe, and so you
should go check out some of his papers
on that topic, but I haven't looked into
that. And I remain somewhat skeptical to
the quantal explanation for
consciousness, but mostly because the
mechanism doesn't appear at first glance
to be very biologically reasonable.
And also that there's essentially not
very much data on it, but that may
change in the coming years. So something
to look out for. Great. One other
question more generally, how do you see
experimental work in the active
inference ecosystem, and how do you see
the synthesis of theoretical and in
principle, work with this kind of real
wet lab and real recordings on the
neurons type analysis that you're doing
here? Yeah, so it's a great question.
I think that what we need to be doing as
a community is having more interactions
between theorists and experimentalists.
And so we wouldn't have performed, for
example, this experiment here if we
hadn't already been inspired by
biological and theoretical models of
predictive coding and of active
inference as well. And so that's really
what we need, is to make not
only hypotheses that are turned into
great theoretical and computational
infrastructures and models,
but we also need to be thinking about if
we care about the biology and we care
about trying to figure out the brain,
then we should also be trying to map
those things onto neurobiology and
psychology. Right? And so that involves
them both considering the
neurobiological elements that may
implement and mediate active inference
in the brain, as well as the
psychological and cognitive constructs
that we think are going to be
particularly sensitive to capture
certain elements of the theory. And so
I remain very welcoming
to that type of and in
fact, there's going to be a postdoc
joining the lab soon, eli Sinesh,
who has been working very deeply
in the active inference community. And
so we'll have an opportunity there to
both work on theory guided data
analysis, but also perform more
theoretically guided experimental
designs that can go further into
the neurobiological implementation. And
so this was here what I've presented
really simply the first and small,
somewhat step towards linking the
neurobiological implementation level
with the algorithmic and computational
level of predictive coding and active
inference. And so the more interactions
that we can have between the
communities, the better that
will be. I think what would
be somewhat of a shame is if the active
inference community went way too far
into just pure theory and
delved into increasing
areas that were divorced from the
biology. So that's, of course, one of
the great critiques, right, of the
deep learning and more machine learning,
purely machine learning driven
approaches, is that they
took a little bit of biological
inspiration, but then started using
algorithms like Backprop that were very
biologically unrealistic. And so, of
course, active inference is a response
to that in certain ways. But in order to
continue being that, I think that there
needs to be indeed a tight dialogue
between experimentalists and theorists.
And so if you have any particular ideas,
I'd be happy to hear them. Please reach
out to me by email or
through X, which you can find here
on the slide. That's really cool.
That's awesome. You're going to be
working with Eli. And one final
question. This is from Alexandra. Is it
possible to detect the contribution of
Glia to the neural firing rate of the
field potentials?
That is a question that I have not
considered yet. So we normally do not
consider Glia to be active
in the network, but of course, that is
likely to be an oversimplification. We
know that they can have interactions
with neurons. We know that they can also
have different levels of excitability,
and of course, that's how they can
regulate neurons metabolically. But as
far as the contributions of Glia
directly to the local field potential,
I am not aware of how to determine
whether or not they make a significant
contribution. I actually haven't
seen any work on that. But thank you for
the question. It's always good to
reconsider our core assumptions, right,
about the cell types that
are most important to capture. So
certainly something to think about.
Thank you. Thank you. All right. Thank
you, Andre. Super cool work. And good
luck with everything. Till next bye.